[Applause]
let's talk about the king
let's talk about the king of new york
bro takashi 6'9
he really is no other rapper in new york
should even mention themselves
as the king because they know they
can't beat him with numbers they know
that the people don't care about their
street cred if that's what you want to
beat him on
and the people don't care enough about
their raps
to discredit takashi for how whack he is
at rhyming
right right like his antics swallow all
them whole
and his songs even though i don't think
he can rap his song slap no he got a
good ear
i'll give that to him or his producer
whoever he works with he's got a good
ear because the songs are catchy
and this one was marketed brilliantly
specifically
obviously his first i think his first
day out now yeah yep first day off house
arrest
first day of house press he's in bed
stuy he's crossing the williamsburg
bridge maybe he's a brooklyn bridge i'm
not sure
he's walking around attack it's his
basically way of saying
hey i'll do whatever i want my first day
i'm not hiding
now granted he's hiding no one knows
what the [ __ ] he is right now but he
found a safe way to go i'm not hiding
i'm not not i'm untouchable i'm a troll
all the gangsters that said i wasn't
gonna walk around
right you come to the hood went to the
hood shot the video in the hood
right he does subtle [ __ ] that's [ __ ]
brilliant
in the video he has this bandage on his
neck
right yeah i thought it was a mask but
it's a bandage
the last scene of the video he he's
driving in the car and a bandage gets
caught in the wind and it throws off
and then it stops i thought he ripped it
off yeah it comes off a little he rips
it off
so now i'm going well what the [ __ ] was
under the bandage
yep now i gotta go to your instagram and
i gotta see if you have any pictures of
your neck
if it's a neck tattoo or whatever the
[ __ ] it is i gotta see
now while i'm on your instagram i'm like
all right it's on and popping i might as
well follow this kid
he's marketing on another level yeah
he's not doing the classic like he
includes the stupid money thing
yeah the stupid change [ __ ] like the
low-hanging fruit of rap pr
look i've got money and it's full he
does do it more obnoxiously though and
it's like more it works better i think
because he's so obnoxious with it
what i don't understand is like why at
what point will other rappers
stop at what point will other rappers
stop
hating and start learning
it's gonna take a long time it took
people a long time with you with comedy
fair enough fair enough yeah it's a lot
of this ain't working this isn't the way
tv is still a thing it's not going away
for 20 years and then it works enough
enough times you get enough million
video views and you're just people like
all right man i guess this is what it is
so rappers aren't there yet they're not
there yet they haven't figured out that
like
ant excel and we don't need you to be
truly authentic because that seems
completely counterintuitive
right yeah i kind of disagree guys
i think the antics are starting to not
work
like he had uh the biggest drop ever in
terms of billboard with his last song
that he came out with
like it was like number two in the
country and then the next week it was
number 125
like some crazy drop right like i think
when you play that antics game and
people start to realize oh you're just
the antics guy
that gets old i'll say this i don't
think that he makes songs
to last forever i think more than a week
no no i i really don't think that he
that they do
i think his goal is actually to treat
the songs as
throwaways i'm gonna surge
with interest on one day i'm gonna spike
all the interest into one day and shoot
it far up to the charts maybe get number
one
and then there'll be zero interest the
next day because there's no real like
nutritional value there
in the music but it doesn't matter
because i got my number one on to the
next one
and he can keep on creating number ones
that people are bored of the next day
it doesn't matter because it's
low-hanging fruit content like it's not
like it works on the bars like kendrick
lamar
or an eminem or or jay-z is like really
crafting these songs
he's just throwing out some so then he's
making
money i would also draw one more
parallel to schultz if i guess you one
more time
go there before comedy there was youtube
stars social media stars antics
the talent isn't really there but they
got the antics and they they spike their
ebb and flow they have their
you know great video whatever takashi we
said it he's not a skilled rapper
but he's gotten this far off just antics
and then when somebody's gonna come
around and combine skill with antics
then it's a game changer and that's what
it's going to take for things to
completely flip it's going to take one
guy
who's going to say a kendrick lamar or
jay caller whoever who can rap and be
like nah you could be
i'm going to have antics that are less
ridiculous but still antics and then be
true to the craft and be a good rapper
and i think then people are going to be
like oh this is a lot of marketing
and smoke and mirrors as much as
anything else yeah i think i agree with
you
it's like and i'm doing that because
you're complimenting me yeah
but uh but yeah you're saying that like
i i brought
quality jokes yeah to the internet where
people were fine with like stupid
sketches where like guys put on wigs
yes and then we like put high quality
stand up on there and people like oh
this is fire
yeah you know and um same thing that
we're doing to monologues in a way so
yeah
it's like i want to make everybody feel
i want everybody else to feel like
um the condom is on
yeah you know what i mean like i want
when you watch our monologues to be like
yo this is raw sex
and then you go watch some of the
competition and you're like yo this is
yeah sex with a condom right but and
that's what it looks like and that's
what
i think archiva's point is really
brilliant is like that that could happen
if the next generation of rapper
understands what a takashi does
yeah and then uses that but also comes
through with real content yeah and real
songs and fire bars
like imagine your favorite rapper
lyrically
had takashi's pr mind
i think that used to be kanye yeah
that's a [ __ ] great that was yay
right it was like a guy who was
decent rap but great at pr
and great at like musical ear making the
music himself
himself yeah that's [ __ ] so true so
we just need the next version of yay to
come up i don't know who that is
that's why life of pablo was so big it
was probably not his best
rap but like antics were high and then
this album
sounds amazing got a couple songs to
slap his bars are kind of whatever but
like
dude this album is great and with the
antics it's a different it was like
i remember everybody going nuts over
life of pablo yeah
that's interesting who do you think the
next will be mark you're in on the these
young rappers
oh yeah jack harlow jack harlow do you
think he's got the antics though
no i don't i'm not really he's too he's
too authentic he's too real yeah
he's too real yeah yeah when you're from
the streets you can't really take it out
of something like that right
no i get it i get it jack is a tough guy
yeah i don't know i mean
maybe like uh roddy rich
like i don't know if he has the antics
like that but like as far as like the
star power behind him like he's got
every cosine
like everyone's gassing them and but
then rap but does he understand the game
does he understand the flex does he
understand not
nah the troll does he understand like
how
interest is drummed up now i don't think
so i don't got it is it possible those
two things can even go together though
because if antics requires
if it's like necessary toughness that's
what i'm saying like if it's necessary
for antics to be like
oh i'm belligerent and like obnoxious
and loud yeah
and then quality to be like i'm
thoughtful introspective and delicate
yeah are those two things like
necessarily even what you're describing
is steph curry it's like
never has somebody who could shoot the
ball so well
i've been able to dribble so well
because there's no need to do it
right like if i can shoot from anywhere
on the car i don't need to learn how to
dribble to get by you
and pass right like yeah it's just it's
redundant and like
i don't need to get by you because i'm
going to shoot from 35 feet and i'm wet
so i don't even need a crossover right
and if you do come out and play d at 35
feet
i could probably get by with one or two
moves yeah it's not that i don't need
every single move which is what steph
has
right so then you have that super unique
talent
which can do both on the basketball
court right that's also going to
transcend to
art in any way stand up like stand-ups
now
because of what we did every stand-up is
going to need to know how at least when
they start to edit videos
post clips do all this that's just
baseline for
know how to operate a camera know how to
use final cut that's
bare minimum if you're a starting
stand-up yeah if you're someone who's
established you could pay someone to do
it
but bare minute they're gonna have to
learn how to do it so we created a new
game
yep where marketing is part of the
[ __ ] game i'll say
the person that was closest within rap i
think is tyler the creator
oh yo when he first came out he was like
he had legit raps and he was like trying
to say something he had like an actual
message in a pov but he was also going
on like
snl and like just [ __ ] around and
like running off stage
his first video with him eating the
[ __ ] bug or whatever yeah exactly
that's
set the internet off yeah yo that's a
good one tyler is interesting
because tyler understands
what it takes to make a moment yeah like
a lot of people will go on the funk flex
freestyle [ __ ]
oh yeah and they try to do their most
fire
freestyle so that flex would go oh my
god you're the [ __ ] and then that goes
viral
and then tyler goes nah you know be
funny if i say some gay [ __ ] and make
him feel
super weird that's going to go viral
tyler
understands the value of interest
and eyeballs but he's fine on his own
island
yeah a little dicky does a little bit
also like he's decent at it where like
he'll make these videos that pop
yeah but the songs are actually pretty
good and like some of his other songs
have like actual bars
it's just you're trying to find the
compatibility between like someone
that's intelligent and smart enough to
know how to market
yeah like write really well but also
like tortured enough to be an artist
exactly torture enough to be willing to
like let themselves be like
and willing to sacrifice a bit of the
art maybe potentially i mean there's
probably a way to do both
but potentially sacrificing the art for
the antics it's a really rare person and
within rap specifically i think it's
hard
best person who probably did it was
eminem yo i was gonna bring up m
it's a different time but his marketing
was crazy
yeah the music and the marketing were
the music was up there the music was
fire i was just listening to eminem
recently the music was fire
like skill wise regardless if you like
watching
he's the one he's an incredible rapper
yeah the skill of rap yeah
and i know people now it's fun to like
look back and be like hey he just goes
simming to him and then him in it the
dude had [ __ ]
bars and he got respect for a reason
yeah absolutely jay-z not putting
anybody on his album
right but you're right he knew how to
drum up the interest he knew how to poke
the right people
yeah teeny boppers is brilliant hell
yeah especially when it was like
it was like the the teeny bopper
olympics back yeah like a new boy brand
or a new girl singing
every other day and he kind of cut
through that
right with like authenticity now it
seems almost a little fraudulent but
back then
then his videos were dope his live
performances were dope like yeah he
would always make a moment where
everybody uh he knew how to make a
[ __ ] moment the mtv music awards
where he's like like me was his song and
he had like 400 [ __ ] 300 people
white kids with platinum blonde hair and
the white t-shirt in the bag
all walking in the line he [ __ ] got
it and you go sorry real quick i also
remember he gave an award speech one
time he got an award same mtv [ __ ]
goes up and his everybody's dressed up
he's got on his [ __ ] tracksuit baggy
ass pants
he's like oh i got a speech somewhere
and then he reaches into his pocket and
i didn't even get it because i was like
13 and mad naive and he just
like a thousand pills fall out of his
pocket and he was like oh my bad
and he just walks off stage it's like yo
he gets the [ __ ] moment
yeah yo i'm pretty sure i think it was
him or stevo i can't remember
but someone was telling me like a merch
story where i think it was him he used
to sell urinal cakes with his face on
him
as like concert merch oh i think that
was stevo was that stevo
yeah i remember being eminem because i
think eminem heard about it was like oh
that's genius
yeah so it was like eminem co-signed it
eminem had a really interesting thing
we need to go back and like look at his
pr because he had this super balance
between like
roasting everybody yeah and also
humility like yeah self-hatred
charlemagne talks about it in uh black
privilege he
grows himself like he would always say
yeah yeah i always get to me before you
can get to me
and then i roast you and i roast me too
what is the [ __ ] yeah it creates a
really interesting authenticity and like
you just feel as if you're hearing
something truthful
yeah you're like oh this guy's not only
calling out himself he's calling out his
audience
yeah he's like hey yeah you guys want to
be like me because i curse a lot and do
[ __ ] up [ __ ]
like it's like there's no fourth wall
yeah or whatever
and the artist that can do that or the
comedians that can do that the people
that can do that
tend to transcend their peers in that
[Applause]
time